age might be just a number but sagging
skin
brittle nails thinning hair or weak
joints can make you look
and feel much older than you are after
30 your body slows down its natural
production of collagen
affecting the way you look and feel but
you can easily boost your body's missing
collagen
with collagen peptides by youngevity
sourced from
clean and sustainable ingredients
collagen peptides provides the five main
collagen types
formulated perfectly together to help
restore your youthful looking skin
hair nails and more plus it's rich in
amino acids
that help promote healthy muscles and
energy production
to help your body better utilize every
dose of collagen peptides
we've added collagen digesting enzymes
to promote optimum absorption
collagen peptides the powerful collagen
boosting formula
specifically created to promote the
health of your hair
skin nails and more helping you prove
that age
is just a state of mind to learn more
contact your youngevity associate